It’s Halloween!
The media say
better watch out.
Halloween is the deadliest holiday
Within minutes this little pirate costume disintegrated.
People are injecting gummies just like this these days
with drugs.
Really?
That’s what we should worry about?
trick or treat
No! That’s absurd.
Those stories have been around for decades.
They’re not true,
though adults find plenty of other things
to worry about.
What do you fear on Halloween?
I'm scared of bats.
Bats?
Yes.
Do you really think they might really hurt you?
I think so because their wings are flapping
and they're really long.
Sharks.
I hate rats, man.
I guess like creepy old people.
Uh oh, does that include me?
I am terrified of spiders.
She believes many Americans
are killed by spiders.
I’m gonna go with at least a thousand.
Actually…three,
says the National Safety Council.
I have an irrational fear of balloons.
Horses.
And you think you're more likely to be killed by a horse
than other risks?
Probably not
but it's our fears are often not very logical.
Exactly! People fear…
Anything that's creepy and unknown right?
I'm super afraid of like clowns.
Clowns.
Why clowns?
They're just a little freaky.
I'm scared they're gonna chase after me.
I just saw It, so I think I'm in that kind of... clowns.
Yeah, I think that’s what I'm scared of right now.
Americans worry about so much.
What might actually
physically harm you?
Gosh, what couldn't kill you over nowadays?
Like murder, maybe?
Everybody's crazy these days.
Mean people.
Trump.
What scares you?
Heights.
Why heights?
Because I can't control it.
Aha, there’s an insight!
Losing control adds to our fears.
In cars
we feel in control,
but flying scares many people.
I got on a plane today and I was freaking out.
Hold on…
there are more than 90 deaths a day
from car crashes,
but no one’s died for years
in a commercial American plane.
I'm scared of getting hit by the subway.
There's a lot of things that scare me today.
There's a lot of things going on in our world
that is scary.
No!
Wait!
Despite all the media hype
about a thousand risks,
life today is safer …than ever before.
It’s not good to fear so much
because fear
is a friend of big government.
Whenever there’s an accident,
the media push politicians to say,
“there ought to be a law!”
Ban all consumer fireworks.
And worried people agree.
No I don't think they should be allowed
unless they're done by professionals.
Vicious dogs need to be regulated.
They’ll bite you
and grab you
and kill you.
We are in grave danger, frankly in this country
because of terrorism.
Terrorism is the big scare now,
but even including 9/11,
death from terrorism is rare.
The National Safety Council says
more people die
crossing the street,
in bathtubs,
or tripping over furniture.
Here in Times Square,
the risk of terrorism is probably higher,
but this man understands
it's still a small risk.
Because if you look at the odds,
you look at the numbers, it's,
it's very small.
The big risks in America today are
eating too much,
drinking too much,
smoking,
and driving recklessly.
What do you worry about?
Bad drivers.
You know, that's the most sensible answer
I've gotten here
all day.
Happy Halloween.
Enjoy the moment.
Life in America is safer
than ever before.